en quête d'une vaccination à plus grande
échelle l'allemagne s'est décidé à
négocier elle même l'achat du spoutnik v
en raison du délai pris par l'union
européenne pour valider le sérum russe
au nom de ses 27 états membres
une décision confirmée sur twitter par
le fabricant du vaccin
urgent le fonds d'investissements
directs russe a entamé des discussions
avec les représentants du gouvernement
allemand sur l'accord d'achat anticipé
de spoutnik v pour l'allemagne ce
mercredi la bavière avait montré la voie
en annonçant la signature d'un pré
contrat de livraison de deux millions
cinq cent mille doses du vaccin
ce jeudi c'est le ministre allemand de
la santé qui s'est exprimé au nom de la
nation
j'ai expliqué au nom de l'allemagne au
conseil des ministres de la santé de
l'union européenne que nous discuterions
de manière bilatérale avec la russie
tout d'abord pour savoir quand et quelle
quantité pourrait être livré les
livraisons devraient intervenir dans les
deux à quatre voire cinq prochains mois
pour vraiment faire la différence avec
notre situation actuelle
parmi les membres de l'union européenne
berlin même pas le seul convaincu de
l'efficacité du vaccin russe en février
la hongrie est devenue le premier pays
de l'espace schengen à administrer le
vaccin suivi de la république tchèque en
slovaquie
le premier ministre a même dû annoncer
sa démission fin mars après avoir
commandé deux millions de doses du
spoutnik b en raison du mécontentement
de son gouvernement
de son côté la france préfère attendre
le feu vert de l'europe avant de prendre
toute décision
on a une agence européenne du médicament
qui étudie les candidats vaccins pour
garantir qu'ils sont sûrs et efficaces
avant les proposer aux citoyens
européens et vous savez que le vaccin
spoutnik est en cours d'examen par l'
agence européenne du médicament dans la
procédure qu'on appelle durling review
sur ce vaccin est encore une fois je
redis la position qui a toujours été la
nôtre qui a toujours été celle que j'ai
porté en tant que porte parole du
gouvernement
c'est que quand il ya des candidats
vaccins ne regardons pas leur
nationalité
nous regardons leur efficacité et leur
sécurité
ce n'est pas de l'avis de l'ensemble de
la classe politique jean-luc mélenchon
président de la france insoumise assure
le contraire ce jeudi
nous nous sommes enfermés dans les
décisions stupides de la bureaucratie
européenne
nous avons refusé pour des raisons
idéologiques de faire venir en france le
vaccin rue
chinois ou cuba qui eux existent et
fonctionnent
il y à 57 pays dans le monde qui ont
recours au vaccin russe on sait depuis
novembre dernier qu'il est efficace par
une mission française qui a abouti à
cette conclusion arme politique ou non
le vaccin spoutnik v semble bien parti
pour diviser l'union européenne au moins
jusqu'au début de l'été